alter
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge der
today show
unser heutiger gast ist den skate 702
weiß man kann es unbeabsichtigt so viel
zum thema übergeleitet da einfach schon
mal wunderbar so toll wir versuchen dann
übrigens auch immer uns mehr an die
themen zu halten das heißt jede folge
ein thema und so weiter und uns wären
die folgen länge zu halten sage ich mal
und ich versuche heute etwas hier
minecraft das lp
da hat er mit einer 3 geschrieben
hilflos schön thema redet doch mal über
hunt l p
wie steht ihr zu ihm kennt ihn und wie
er sich so entwickelt hat bzw entwickeln
könnte in der zeit in der wir das
besprechen kann sich schon mal hier in
unserem genau hinterfragen muss
das ist unser status zusammengebaute
amex tradition machen für die
freigelegten alles mögliche das ist
alles für mich das alles ganz einfach
ist noch werke kannst du machen was der
ganzen ja schon eigentlich alles
aufbauen wer viel spaß hier in deinem so
werden wir ihn jetzt ein dahinvegetieren
okay wir hatten ein thema reden also
erstmal wir in der folge das macht 35
vielleicht oder der jahr 35 contango
haben wir schon angst ums geld irgendwo
essen
darüber haben wir gesagt wir haben heute
keinen gaspar man dann allerdings
einfach improvisiert und gesagt dass
dieses huhn unser gast sein was bei dem
so kaputt gelaufen ist haben einfach
gesagt ja das ist so imposant wie wir
halt sind improvisiert ich improvisiere
egal also spontan wie wir heiße jetzt
sowieso egal so spontan wie weit hinter
mir dann gesagt ja wir haben hunderte zu
gast und dann den halt nachgeguckt gibt
es wirklich einen youtube und den gab es
noch nicht und dann hat sich einer
diesen account erstellt und wir haben
gesagt ja erstellt euch den mal denn der
bis 300.000 ostseite echt geil und
bleibt so was haben dann halt gesagt das
wird ein echter erstellt und dieser
kanal existiert und immer noch hat
glaube ich 1500 abonnenten oder so um
den dreh und jetzt haben wir natürlich
clipfish wert und meinen ja ist er voll
scheiße von euch dass ihr sohn sonntag
macht ich meine also ich sag das mal
ganz kurz
jeder hat die gleichen voraussetzungen
das muss man einfach so sagen dass die
leute sich also die leute sind auch die
haben sich nun ganz schwer dass das doch
unfair sei das jetzt gibt dieser eine
der da nichts gemacht hat einfach so
gepusht wird und sie selbst meistens
nicht das argument wald immer ich mache
hier soundsoviel lange zeit versuche ich
eine gute videos zu machen und irgendwie
mich so zu steigern
und dann kommt tun lp an den er gar
nichts gebracht hat nur glück dass er
erster ist und hat seine 2000 abonnenten
nach drei tagen gehabt jetzt auch nicht
mehr haben schon wieder viele die
abonniert oder so geld mal ganzjahres
meine würde hinter genau das wollte ich
nämlich parat fragen weil schon mal ganz
kurz hier ist nämlich unsere komplette
farm seit man damit muss letztlich
gucken am geilsten wäre es eigentlich
wenn er das irgendwie hierzu hin bauen
könnte man hier noch platter dann töten
dann natürlich kein bergner weil ich
hatte mir gedacht guck mal da hinten
rechts an dem haus vorbei da auf dem
berg drauf wenn wir auch noch sein
werden dann macht das das ist übrigens
von lp mit cap hier sehr schön sind so
schwer daraus bis jetzt und was was ich
auch mal fragen wollte euch in den
kommentaren
was halt davon wenn dinge und ich mal
irgendwie so als special irgendwann mal
so eine folge machen wo wir wirklich
eine stunde lang einfach nur rum laufen
und über samt sachen hier reden die hier
schon gebaut wurden paar sachen zeigen
also das wollte ich mal fragen weil mir
das oft geschrieben wird dass seine
leute nun anfangen die täter schon zu
gucken natürlich keinen plan mehr haben
wer schon alles da was gebaut hat das
können wir erst mal waren also das
fernglas speziellen folgen zahl 60 oder
50 schaffen 50 glaubt 50 zu nah dran
50 ist war das wäre auf jeden fall mal
eine idee die man nachvollziehen ich
glaub ich habe immer nur rum und macht
nichts ich wollte jetzt eigentlich
gerade die idee gehabt jetzt laufen sich
in die höhle dann gehe ich hab keine
fackeln aber jetzt viel anderes zeug
jetzt ist erstmal weg danke ich in hülle
aber wir können schon das thema reden
ich will mal hier am anfang eher zu
sagen ich hab diesen part durch zufall
gesehen weil ich mal wieder auf
kontraste so vorbei geguckt habe wie ich
es mir dann meinen was wegen kann kannst
du kann in villach stimme ich hatte mir
angewöhnt leute in aufnahmen immer
länger zögern also ich habe auf lukas
stern vorbei geguckt und hab dann
gesehen wie hohn lp da muss er extrem
bekannt sein wenn er hier in warschau
dabei ist und dann habe ich 100 ps
gibt's da nicht da habe ich geguckt
arbon lp wurde noch nicht erstellt euch
überlegt zu drei sekunden lang hatte ich
den gedanken okay es geht jetzt machst
du ne lp damit aber gedacht
die chance lasse ich jetzt wirklich mal
jemanden der die nutzen will und dann
hat sie genutzt ich finde das einfach
irgendwie ich finde das richtig aus es
ist genial
ich finde das jetzt geschafft hat ohne
irgendwie ein video
da seine ersten tausend abonnenten hat
er gleich ohne video geschafft in einem
tag und das hast du heute irgendwie dass
es überhaupt noch möglich ist ohne dass
die leute jetzt vielleicht sofort sagen
kenne ich nicht ist doof abonniere ich
nicht gebe ich keine chance aber was
dann halt ich hätte halt doch dass es
irgendjemand ist der vielleicht daraus
was macht weil ich habe das gefühl dass
der der das jetzt sozusagen geschafft
hat diesen kanal dazu erstellen
naja das der halt und eine sehr lustlose
stimme hat und man bekommt
gerade wenn man ja diese chance hat sage
ich mal
das soll letztlich arrogant oder
eingebildet oder so kommen aber wenn man
die chance hat von uns mehr erwähnt zu
werden das sind ja dann schon so ein
paar leute die dann auf den kanal von
dieser person gehen und dann sollte man
ja eigentlich so eine chance aus nutzt
also normaler mensch wird das natürlich
machen ich habe mein herz auf ausgenutzt
hat auch videos gemacht da dachte ich
schon so ok cool
die rub mit seinem channels kommt
bestimmt richtig content und wir haben
wieder einen neuen let's play die szene
mit rein integriert und dann kommen da
wirklich zwei videos und jetzt kam durch
ein video
ja ich höre jetzt auf neuen kanal
verstehe ich nicht er fasst vor allem
die videos waren von anfang an sofort
monetarisiert mit voller werbung auch
mit nur mit schöner pre-roll werbung
drauf also also sofort adsense aktiviert
alles was an anzeigen geht drauf und
stadt dass man einfach sich erst mal
vielleicht denken so wie mache ich jetzt
gute videos abonnenten die wollte
irgendwas sehen ich muss mich jetzt ich
muss echt gucken dass irgendwas gutes
produzierte wie mache ich das
aber du hast du alles den kisten
ausgenommen naja ich hab ich doch nun
komplett leer gemacht
ich suche nur kohle kann ich mich in der
höhle gehen weil ich keine kohle für
fackeln habe und du läufst ihr mit 20
spektrum spitzhacken ich dachte ich
nehme einfach mal alles raus und was
mich überlebt das kann ja wieder rein
tun
diese skelette und alles hat die zombies
an scheiße für alle was auf da
vielleicht sollten wir erstmal schlafen
da müsstest du erstmal einen haus gehen
von von irgendeiner person die hier
schon mal da war mittlerweile alles
mittlerweile so recycling häuser hier
mal wieder verwendet den job bei dem ich
habe jetzt erst joint steht bei mir an
ehe das ist vom chat von vorhin haus
dann jedoch darauf hat sich am bett oder
er hatte
wo aus das haus epische hat er in zwei
stunden geschafft ja du siehst was die
messlatte für dich ist okay da sind
vorbei das ist wohl stimmen
na ja ich wollte etwas zu 100 ps sagen
und zwar kam er dann da viele leute an
und meinten bisschen mehr das heißt
viele es waren jetzt weniger was ich da
hätte nicht gedacht dass es doch so
viele sind sage ich mal die da meinten
dass er voll scheiße dass er sowas macht
ich meine ich kann mich nur wiederholen
jeder hatte wirklich die gleiche chance
er hatte halt das glück sage ich mal
dass in folge gesehen hat soll es mit
einer der ersten hat man ja meistens
über das glück er hat nicht erst in die
kommentare geschrieben zumindest
jedenfalls die chance genutzt den kanal
erstellt hatte den kanal dann hat dann
relativ viele abonnenten bekommen und
ich meine da habe ich mich dann schon
für ihn gefreut sage ich mal weil jeder
hätte ich finde es traurig dass viele
leute ihnen den erfolg nicht gönnen sag
ich nur
rdx auch im bett ich lege gleich im bett
in einem doppelbett pkw tür ist könnte
ein kühlversuch mit mir zu kuscheln
heute nacht weil ich jetzt halt echt
kugelform inhalt dann gute videos
produziert hätte und dann erfolgreich
seinen youtube weg geht durch das
gegenteil wird sozusagen der fall weil
jetzt ein add ins kontor der
mitgeschrieben gesperrt wurde wegen
ungültiger klick aktivitäten das
passiert wenn man zu häufig selber drauf
klickt selber auf die werbung geklickt
verstehe ich schon so hell wie kann man
nur so was machen das steht da sogar
ganz den regeln klicken nicht selber
deine videos an oder dann wären die
nicht liest und naja kurz und deswegen
golf muss ich neuen kanal erstellen
neuer bin ja nicht den kurs lp info
video nummer 3 eher der erde eines play
voll glaube ich und drei info videos und
eine vorstellung von einem kumpel von
ihm sowie die nummer drei hey leute es
das letzte video auf dem kanal
ich hab mir zu nelsons lp gemacht wäre
cool wenn ihr da auch vorbei geht
ich bin auf ich kriege noch viel zu
android
lucias tisch in wirklichkeit könnte auch
mal ein tumor sind jetzt auch nicht so
ich sag mal fertig machen obwohl es
nicht wirklich fertig machen ist aber es
wird von vielen halt wieder so
aufgefasst
das soll es soll nicht fertig machen ist
einfach tatsache ein meinem ein video
fertig geworden der aufnahmen gehört
weil er sonst schön zumal sie auch
wirklich meint er hätte ja die chance
nutzen können und sich dann einfach mal
informieren können ja okay weil die abo
steigen ja sag ich mal bei ihm so oder
so also die sind ja so oder so
angestiegen sage ich mal setzt dann
schon informieren können bevor er
werbung schaltet über die regeln dann
vielleicht ja was soll ich muss ich ihn
und videos machen weil die akkus bleiben
natürlich nicht meine ist viele
abonnieren bestimmt einfach nur weil wir
so gesagt haben so abonniert den mal
vielleicht schaffen wir so viele damen
so gedacht komm das schaffen wir weil
wir die kleine community sind abnehmen
wie die male hat er irgendwie 1500
abonnenten innerhalb von 30 stunden oder
so und er muss ihm eigentlich schon
bewusstsein von wegen jahr die sind
jetzt alle da wollen hier etwas sehen
und wenn sich mein video the box sehen
auf youtube auf der startseite
dann wollen wir natürlich nicht denken
dass jetzt wieder viele neigen opponiert
den ob de abonniert jetzt wieder sondern
die wollen natürlich auch gute sachen
sehen
deswegen würde ich vor allem sagen dass
dieses erste video ganz wichtig ist und
wirklich den leuten zu zeigen da bleibt
jetzt er da oder euro gehen jetzt er weg
und das hat er sage ich mal verklagt
weil er halt gegeben
info videos und push push the video ohne
seine stimme sondern ist musik für die
nicht mehr die rechte hatte darunter
gelegt und info video ganz schlecht
gleiche wenn wenn man halt so eine
chance bekommt dann wenn man es steht in
kraft tritt wenn man so eine chance hat
dann macht man sich da irgendwie sollte
man sich eigentlich irgendwie gedanken
darum machen und sich denkt ja wie wie
schaffe ich jetzt dann irgendwie ein
halbwegs gutes video draus zu machen
aber das kann man so als ob sie echt gar
nicht mal wirklich gedanken darüber
gemacht wurde sondern einfach und so
seien die videos auch aus
wie gesagt es war eine chance und ich
fand ihr auch die idee auch cool das
muss man mal so sagen an die neider da
draußen sage ich mal
jeder hätte diese chance nutzen können
auch ich sogar der sitzt gerade das
lustige auch wenn es für mich jetzt eher
unpraktikabel gewesen wäre und einfach
eine verschwendung von der kommune für
jemand neuen sag ich mal
aber naja wie man sie nutzt hat jedem
selber überlassen und er hat es jetzt
halt eher weniger nutzt sag ich mal
also ich denke dass ich vielleicht
irgendwann sowas nochmal machen werden
das wird bestimmt noch mal irgendwann
passieren dieser kompletten kletter show
aber aber ich sag dir schaafs lps jetzt
auch vergeben denken wir irgendwas
anders aus nicht lp sondern ihnen die
gameplay tun
jetzt wird der player erstellt vergiss
es irgendwelche coolen challandes ist
das wäre auch das war so bei huhn lps
hat sich nicht nur huhn lpg gründe
sondern man lg im dunkel er ist hat sich
ein huhn apple sondern es hat sich 100
p2 hat sich auch gegründet und hat sogar
800 abonnenten bekommen 800 alte weil
wir hatten erfolgen p2 gesagt dass mit
dem machte zusammen
hier hat haben sie ein gab es aber
wirklich gemacht und daher wollen sie
haben sie sogar kann 8 ausgelöst
nur weil wir das zu sein da sieht man
wieder was wir hier so viel einfluss
haben
das ist das ist echt gigantisch das
hätte ich jetzt aber nicht gedacht dass
es in dem ausmaß ist